bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bon début
de semaine il reste 48 heures à justin
trudeau pour choisir ses ministres qui
fera son retour ou sont entrés au
gouvernement on aura toutes les réponses
mercredi matin 10 heures
mais on a déjà quelques unes de ses
réponses ce soir grâce à notre chef de
bureau a entre autres emmanuelle
latraverse bonsoir manuel sera pas
triste
un premier nom celui de stéphane dion
incontournable dans l'équipe de monsieur
trudeau mais surprise il n'irait pas
l'environnement non celui qu'on voit que
monsieur environnement et depuis son
passage dans ce ministère au
gouvernement martin mais c'est ailleurs
que le destine le sucre dos et pète à
l'image des choix que veut faire le
nouveau chef le chef libéral donc
imprimé sa marque sur ce ministère
stratégique
à quelques semaines de la conférence de
paris monsieur dion d'après ce qu'on
entend ne serait pas en reste pour
autant il se verrait possiblement confié
le vaste chantier de toute la réforme
démocratique que veut entreprendre
monsieur trudeau se sait réforme du mode
de scrutin réforme du sénat et tout et
tout les autres donc ses jo lang un
politicologue emmanuel qu'ils
retourneraient un peu aux théories sur
les systèmes de scrutin que cette erreur
mais là on passe du défi de mettre ces
théories en pratique et de nommer
monsieur dion serait une façon d'envoyer
le sien et que monsieur trudeau est
sérieux quand il parle de ces réformes
la caisse qui est pas seulement des
promesses en l'air d'autres ministres ou
s'il ya bien sûr mélanie joly notre le
beaucoup parlé pendant la campagne
électorale
eco trouve hôtel atterrir ce qu'on
entend c'est qu'elle irait possiblement
au ministère du patrimoine
parmi les autres noms à surveiller il y
aura aussi bien sûr marc garneau et lui
à montréal mais aussi un nouveau venu en
politique jean yves duclos l'économiste
de l'université laval à qui on
destinerait un important ministère
économique donc là ça sera jean yves
duclos une des vedettes montantes au
parti libéral du canada et de l'équipe
économique manifestement de monsieur
trudeau et manuel voir des déçus la wii
il va avoir des déçus parce que quand
monsieur trudeau promet un petit cabinet
c'est moins de 30 soit 180 quelques
députés ça fait beaucoup
déçu pour garder en tête que monsieur
trudeau veut un cabinet à l'image de la
diversité et de la réalité du canada ça
ça veut dire ministre dans chaque
province dans les grandes régions
urbaines les gens qui représente
l'expérience canadienne sa diversité
culturelle morale de l'histoire il ya
des choix difficiles et cruelle dire
certains qui s'en viennent les députés
d'expérience qu'on voyait comme étant
assuré d'un poste aux cabinets des gens
qui ont bien servi monsieur trudeau se
voient exclus
je peux vous donner un exemple parmi ce
lot qu'on connaît là c'est pablo
rodriguez le député de la région de
montréal qui est aux côtés de monsieur
trudeau depuis les débuts de la course à
la direction était le président de la
campagne au québec c'est lui qui lui a
trouvé les candidats qui donne ce fork
tus québécois et bien être un homme dans
une ville trop blanc mais des fois c'est
difficile et lui doit on doit passer son
tour est sacrifié pour que monsieur
trudeau plus surtout aussi respecter sa
promesse de la parité hommes femmes au
sein du conseil des ministres mais voilà
on a des jeunes meilleure idée merci
manuel travail